oh it's not a game sweetheart and i mean
that most sincerely
[Music]
here we are second half
the zygon inversion home of an epic
speech from the 12th doctor
but doesn't have much else going on
some a little
it's not as good as i remember it i
think largely just because i remember
that
speech and that speech
is aces but um the rest of the episode
is fine it's okay
it's better than the last one it doesn't
have the same massive glaring makes me
want to just
pull on my hair kind of issues
or scenes that were as painful as some
of the ones in the zygon invasion were
so it's better
it is a step up it's just not the
massive leap i think i had
really wanted it to be except for that
one speech
but uh we will get there so at the front
end we've got
clara in this sort of dreamscape which
is uh actually very cool and very well
realized i think because
um it it touches on the sorts of things
that you get in dreams like
looking at a digital clock and like it
reads wrong and backwards because that's
the kind of thing that just looks
wrong in a dream uh or you know
toothpaste is the wrong color you know
these
little things throwing it off i like
that they don't tease that out for too
long i mean there was no point we knew
she was in the pot or whatever i just
think it's
well visualized and well realized this
sort of putting her in
what would mentally be a fairly cozy
place i.e i.e her apartment but there's
a bunch of subtly wrong things with it
and plus through the tv she can kind of
communicate
now speaking of the communication
and what goes on between her and bonnie
um i'm a little bit torn
on the one hand i do kind of
i like the idea that
car can kind of get in on
almost involuntary things you know
things that are so
quick the sorts of things that um
you know could be almost unconscious or
subconscious things like winking
or you know a very simple text you know
with the hand while
while bonnie's just walking along i do
kind of like that
here's an aspect of it i don't like
though and
i might i i
think i still would have but i will
admit i might not have singled this out
as being a problem
were it not for stuff that goes on later
with clara in this series
and that is we don't get an explanation
as to why
she's able to exert as much
direct influence on bonnie as she does
to the point at one point when bonnie's
interrogating her forcing her to change
back into his icon for a hot minute
and that degree never gets an
explanation
and because there isn't even a token
explanation that i caught
as to why clara is able to
be this directly mentally
confrontational towards
the zygon and we've never seen evidence
of that happening
ever before well
then it seems to happen basically just
because clara's the best
she's she's amazing why can she do this
she just can
because she's clara
yeah um like i i wouldn't like that
regardless but
knowing things that go on later and
feeling that some of the reason
that moffat felt justified in doing some
of the stuff that comes later seems to
be rooted in this idea of clara is the
best this feels like the sort of thing
that is artificially
pumping up her value and her uniqueness
and her specialness
not just to the doctor because every
companion
should be special to the doctor they're
traveling with
but just like as a person she can just
fight back harder and with more impact
than we have ever seen happen before
because that's not being extra special
to the doctor
that's being the most extra special
thing in the freaking universe
and no look when we get to the speech i
am going to gush a little bit so i'm
trying to get most of my issues
that i have with this thing out of the
way at the front end here
so the fact that kate turned out not to
be a zygote in fact was
kate that she survived that's not a big
surprise however what's really
dumb and lame is that they treat it like
a big surprise reveals that
how did she survive she survived by
having a gun and apparently being
confronted by a zygon
so slow that she had time to
unholster her sidearm fi pointed and
fire it five times before the zygon that
was prepared to take her out at any
moment
could get a hit off ugh
like i like that kate survived i like
kate but that's
what's what's the big tactical trick
she used the gun she brought wow
i don't even have a problem with that's
how she got away it's just treated like
a reveal and that's a reveal of
well duh what else was she gonna do
okay okay here's a good thing here's
something i do like i really do like the
interactions between
uh the doctor and osgood and i
i like that she's got his number like
more than possibly anybody who hasn't
actually traveled with the doctor
ever has his number and
i enjoy that and makes their
interactions a lot of fun
in in a way it almost kind of creates an
argument and of itself as to why she
should never be an ongoing companion
because she
already knows the doctor so well you
would lose that element of the companion
learning about discovering and getting
to know the doctor she already knows the
doctor super well
you can still get something out of it
but like it's a dynamic i like seeing
as a one-off or an occasional i wouldn't
want that necessarily to be the regular
interactions
from the get-go for a companion but it
is a lot of fun here
um minor points and maybe if i wasn't
uh gender fluid and embroiled in and
more
keenly aware of trans issues than i
would have been at the time this
aired maybe this wouldn't bother me but
um
why does the doctor keep calling her
zygella these things have happened
zygella they are facts
like there isn't really a reason given
for that i mean maybe it's to antagonize
her but
why he he shouldn't want to antagonize
her
actually for the most part he doesn't
seem to want to except for where he's
trying to prod her and get her to think
but
ticking her off over calling her the
wrong name doesn't
do that it just seems dickish
she told you her name she told you her
identity
and you're ignoring it to call her what
sounds
like a species slur
i don't know why that's there and i and
i'm sure i just triggered everyone who's
gonna go ah you total sjw only you
people will complain about that okay
fine but why is it there then if that's
the only reason it bothers me i'd still
like get explanations to why it happens
have you got one i don't coming back to
some idiocy
so um so the osgoodes can get to the
osgoode box
makes sense the doctor can get to the
ozgood box
makes total sense clara can get to it
yeah okay yeah
fine how does she get to it it scans her
body print
i'm sorry what in a situation
that involves shape shifters
the way she gets access is by
body print by looking a certain way
you have shape shifters their entire
thing is adopting someone else's body
print
how is that a security measure oh and
one other
dumb thing uh the zygon who bonnie
forced to turn back into alien form and
took the video of
uh is hiding like
not even a block from where the
footage was taken now look i'll buy
that nobody that lives there cares
because that kind of
got established where nobody in this
estate
is phased by anything they watch this
thing transform and run off and they
just kind of sit there
but the video went viral you're telling
me that no authorities
went out here because if they did they
would have looked
in a why they would have done a search
in enough space to have found him
so this video went viral is being
reported on the news and no authority
figures showed up
to this guy hiding two buildings down
really okay so
let's get to the speech this speech is
great
not only because of capaldi's delivery
of it and he delivers it
like a boss he has so much
to do here he has so many things to
convey
and so many modes to switch in and out
of and that's a big thing for me i
love that he turns on a diamond to
something that makes sense for the
tactic he's trying to use to get bonnie
to change her mind about what she's
trying to do
i love all of that so like he starts out
kind of flipping
with this american game show host voice
kind of thing
and we're our fingers on buzzers are you
feeling lucky are you ready to play the
game
until it gets really serious he just
looks keep the eye goes because it's not
a game cake
this is a scale model of war like that's
great
and talking to bonnie being dismissive
like in the way a parent would be
we've been treated like cattle so what
we've been left to fend for
ourselves what says everyone it's not
fair oh
it's not fair it's forcing her or trying
to force her to confront
how petty she's being and he's really
accurate
when he calls her a tantrum-y child
and that is done really about those
shifts in tone and when he gets more
serious and when he
backs off a little bit when he gets
hopeful because i want to get you to see
and i'm almost there
the the give and take and flow of it is
great now i did mention in my greatest
uh doctor who speeches
video that i do think it goes on a
little
too long it's i think it's just when he
gets shouty at the end
this is not a war i fought in a bigger
war
than you will ever know i did worse
things than you could ever imagine when
i close my eyes
like it gets all it gets dialed up to 11
and it probably should have stayed at 10
but other than but that doesn't kill it
it totally works and the thing is
this whole interaction comes back to
what i said last time
understanding radicalization
understanding what it is she wants to
accomplish
and why it is so hard to pull
people back because
she has made decisions to do things and
to try and force
others like her to either be like her
or or to make the world hate them as
much as it hates her so that they will
feel they have to do what she wants them
to do
and that is such a base little tactic of
radicalization
part of it is is that you actually
make the rest of the world see you
in the worst possible light so that they
come at you
as a group and then you can radicalize
the other members of your group who
aren't that far along yet
who aren't at that radical end but you
spur on a reaction
from the majority who clamps down
and they clamp down on everybody not
just the radicals
everyone in that group and then you know
what becomes a lot easier to get people
to go oh you know what
you're right we do have to fight
back we have to make and wage
war they've driven us to it when in
reality
this well the reality is super more
complicated than this
but this faction within is deliberately
trying to push things
harsher they want a harsh reaction so
that they can garner
more support within their community and
like i said
this may have been intended originally
for muslim radicalization but i think it
actually
maps on very well to online
radicalization you know and
the rise of a lot of stuff a lot of very
unpleasant
stuff that has gone on in the years
since this originally aired
i think it tracks for that kind of
radicalization as well
and again it shows a very strong
understanding and especially
and this is why it's so hard for some
for some people to get out
the doctor says look just stop just
don't do it
i started it i will not stop it you
think they'll let me go after what i've
done
because that's a big thing if you can
get people to
to if you can push them enough then
they will believe and they may even be
right but they will believe that well i
can't go back
the other side will not accept me after
the things i've already done
so i might as well keep pushing forward
the way i'm already going
and that's what lends so much power to
the doctor saying well here's the
unforeseeable
i forgive you after all you've done
that moment has a lot of power and this
is why because it
disarms the self-defense mechanism
of people who radicalize and because a
big part of
justifying to yourself is believing that
you can't
go back so that even if you start to
question
the morality or the value of what it is
you're doing
you look at what you've already done and
go well i can't they'll never take me
back
i have no choice i have to go deeper i
have to go harder
no you don't and that's what the doctor
is speaking towards
and it's great it's phenomenal
and rather undercut by a somewhat tossed
offline at the end
which i've never liked and a re-watch i
actually kind of hate
and it's at the very end after the
speech
after everyone has stood down and it
gets established that
there's nothing in the boxes it's just
buttons and
then you know kate says well it won't
work anymore because now we know
and the doctor says well you know you've
said that the last
15 times and wipes your memory i don't
have a problem with the fact that he
wiped her memory to reset it
i have a problem with the last 15 times
line
you're telling me that 15 times things
got bad enough that we showed up in this
row
that to me says that whatever it was
that was worked out
needs to be worked out again because it
keeps failing over and over and over
again the same way
and then this k i mean who knows if it
was as bad as this one each time
but in this instance at the very least
people have died dozens of people
and zygons that we know of have died
find a different system
i mean maybe it wasn't this bad every
time because maybe if both osgoods were
around they were the ones managing it
instead of the doctor
but 15 times
15 times things got so bad that kate and
some zygon maybe bonnie maybe another
one were prepared to try and wipe out
a ton of people and risk wiping out
their own people
and you're just gonna keep that system
in place
look obviously if it's 16 15 times that
fail-safe is pretty solid but like
work on everything up to that point so
that we don't keep getting to this
fail-safe where people have
died
that really ticks me off because it does
take the wind out of
phenomenal speech at the end uh the two
oz goods i covered that
last time and uh and one other thing
that bugs me
the doctor saying that what stopped
bonnie was that clara oswald
got in her head and making the
comparison to when he almost used the
moment in the day of the doctor
said you know there was a box
and it would have wiped out my own
people and i almost pressed it but the
same thing that stopped you
stopped me and that was clara oswald got
in my head
that again like the clower being able to
sort of fight back
that bothers me in context of this
series as a whole
because it's putting again this big
underline
uh on under how special clarity is and
it's not an inaccurate description
she did stop him but that's the role of
the companion that would have been the
role of
any companion in that situation no
matter who the comedian was in the day
of the doctor would have been the
campaign's job to stop the doctor from
doing that
it just happened to be clara but we're
putting this massive emphasis under
clara clara clara specifically
not just the companion not just the
person in that role not
other people who have been there for the
doctor this
one specifically and
again while not inaccurate it's
one more little grain of rice on the
on the scale for some reason mulan's on
my mind you know a single grain of rice
can tip the scale i don't know why
but it's just one more grain of rice on
the scale that is saying
clara is the most awesome and fantastic
and spectacular companion in the history
of the entire franchise and i hate that
it's not the most glaring instant of it
but that coupled with
her fighting back for no adequately
explained reason
and this it is one more contributing
instance of it
and knowing what all these things are
going to add up to
in hell bent and how much i hate that
it's just jumping out at me more
and it's a shame because that's speech
though
oh man so i got inversion
you rewatched it lately what do you
think about it whatever your thoughts
are drop something on down in the
comments and let's talk about it
i've got a patreon keeps these lights on
and
keeps the whole thing going right now
and if you
are are unable to assist me in that way
there is also the usual stuff
like share subscribe and uh hit the bell
all that sort of things they all help me
out but no pressure because at the end
of the day
you are the council i just run the
meetings and until next time this
council
is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]